as Aristotle continues to heal
applications for adoption pour in from
around the country but best friends
needs to find just the right home a
family who can keep up with Aristotle's
emerging exuberance and accept his
unusual appearance he was a little hard
to look at and we knew that we needed to
find someone that was willing to look
past all that to adopt him dr. Mike also
has a wish list for Aristotle's
perspective parents
Aristotle still doesn't have a lot of
fur and so he's gonna be prone to
getting sunburned so an ideal home for
Aristotle would be one like in the
Pacific Northwest where there's not a
lot of Sun and where his family can be
attentive to his special needs and are
willing to deal with the complications
from those things and a home that is
prepared for a doctor has a lot of
energy is very energetic
with about 15 promising candidates to
choose from Dogtown picks the ideal
family for Aristotle
come on everybody sit Phil and Suzie
Alger live in Southwest Oregon with more
than a few dogs thanks guys
so let's see we have Molly Maggie Joleen
Peter Jack Milo
Ben and Ari and I think I did that in
the order that they come come on
everybody
hmm most of the Alger's dogs arrived
with medical or behavioral issues
aristotle seemed like a natural fit come
on there we go
good job this is normally how I watched
Kidman come on go for it huh go for it
there you go
Phil recalls the first photo of
Aristotle he saw from the guardian angel
website oh my god he looked he looked
like a kid that was learning how to ride
a skateboard just cover was gaps and no
fur scary-looking and I thought okay
nobody else wants woman we'll take him
it was that easy
that's really all it takes for us just
as dr. Mike predicted the cool Oregon
climate has proven beneficial to
Aristotle with the climate change I
really think it is helping him because
he doesn't seem to be scratching this
much
oh yeah such good attention his skins
improved dramatically and he's grown
back most of his hair but Aristotle will
still need special treatment come on
buddy I'll be quick okay it'll be real
quick come on real quick
along with daily antiparasite medication
and regular antibacterial baths
Aristotle needs saline eyedrops
throughout the day sometimes he might
get a ten times a day some you know even
more because his eyelids are turned up
it just doesn't lubricate their well
enough or flush out the eyes they get
dried out cuz I never completely close
come on Pete Suzie and Phil go out of
their way to make all their dogs
comfortable their backyard was
landscaped with the dogs in mind from
plants they can't harm to a saltwater
pool at their disposal
we call it the dog pond because the dogs
actually use it a lot more than we do
buddy
when it's time to take the dogs out the
Alger's tend to go to extremes okay come
on guys let's go up in the rig and
that's just what an active dog like
Aristotle needs today's adventure at the
Oregon Dunes National Recreation Area
requires some special gear Aristotle
sports a sweater for wind protection and
warmth gonna have to have these for
extra safety Phil's got something that
may or may not work the goggles will
keep sun sand and wind from aristotle's
to sensitive eyes is that better now
that Sun a little better let me tighten
this up a smidge there you go check it
out let me see let me see dude you are
stylin I don't think he realizes we're
taking him out to like the world's
biggest sandbox
when we go somewhere we go as a family
the pets have always been a part of the
family so the bed's go sometimes there's
more dogs than people but
you did boy for keeping your goggles on
the whole time just keep mine a little
longer okay thank you he's gone through
quite a bit and as soon as our he came
to the house he became all it became the
whole group he's really blended in he's
just a special little guy here plus he's
the only one that wears cool clothes
over time
thanks to Dogtown the fragile little dog
was once too painful to look at now has
all the friends and family he'll ever
need